[Music]
the reaction from your fire I have not
read one negative response for me it is
so moving
it is so deep for me that these
strangers were so happy that I was happy
that I wasn't alone when the headlines
announced that Barry Manilow had married
his longtime partner Gary Keith It was
as if they were also announcing that
Barry was gay something he hadn't spoken
about until now is it something that
you've been wanting to share for a while
um you know it never really dawned on me
this is my life
we've been together for all these years
everybody knows that we're at work were
team I mean I'm a very private guy you
know and I don't even like people
knowing the names of my dogs
we've been with Barry since et first
went on the air in 1981 one key to his
success
don't let fame go to your head I did
American Idol a couple of times and I
saw these very young kids suddenly
become famous I just loved it and all
you can do is say a prayer because I
know what's about to happen to them and
you've got to be really grounded to
handle fame thankfully Barry is only
getting started his new album this is my
count songs of New York is out April
21st and beginning in May he'll hit the
road for a limited series of concerts
you can't get rid of me that's right you
can't get literally I'll be I'll be
making music until I croak
[Music]